[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by sylvia hooks aka
queen kane in c we are gonna be talking
spoilers for episodes one two three
season two so make sure you watch those
first before this interview having said
that sylvia how you doing today
i'm good how are you
i'm doing great so i was so excited to
talk to you because i'm absolutely in
love with your character on this show
and i think what a lot of people can
agree with me on that is that what's so
interesting is that
you don't know what's gonna happen with
your character when she's on screen it's
so interesting to watch
was this something you had in mind when
you were bringing her to life like
adding certain tics to her like how did
you kind of go about that
yeah um
yeah actually um
i had a lot
they're giving me a lot of freedom on
the show which is really nice
because
i really wanted to portray sorry am i on
screen i don't know
i really wanted to portray
an evil queen that um has some crazy
tics to her and is in a different way
evil i did like i love playing bad guys
girls
uh
and i i feel very strongly about
representing them in a way that you can
find some understanding or
laugh at their craziness or
have a little i want there to be a
little bit of an opening for the
audience to step into and see their
world so that's how i kind of um
went on to discover queen kane and
uh yeah i just basically what i normally
do with prepping for a role is
just watch a lot of things
do a lot of research and it's sometimes
various things come to me and this time
i went more into the androgynous vibe
and i and i ended on an interview with
lou reed who
was
high as a kite doing interviews
with uh
journalists and just
you know just [ __ ] with them
basically he
had these big
sunglasses on and you know they were
asking him all sorts of questions about
his album and about drugs and heroin and
i remember him answering like what is
drugs i don't know what you're talking
about i never do drugs and he just kept
going on and on and on and just taking
him
you know
and it was just so fun to see this
intelligent man
fantastic beautiful artist
uh you know
just um just [ __ ] with them basically
and
i
i kind of got a little bit of a sense of
oh that's kind of what i want to do with
the character that's that's what i want
to do and and uh and i
i found this kind of rhythm in his voice
that was interesting
and and i i
i guess i still took i took that and i
took it a step further and i created a
little bit of a weird musical
cadence for the for the voice i don't i
don't know where that exactly came from
but yeah that came yeah when i was
working on it basically
wow that that's so fascinating of an
answer too because like usually people
say like characters from other tv shows
or film but you're taking a real life
figure in lou reed i think that's really
interesting and shows how much you
actually put into the prep which is
awesome um now speaking of characters
that people are going to inevitably
compare queen kane to
do the comparisons to queen cersei from
game of thrones is that something you
like or does that kind of bug you in a
sense hearing that
no doesn't bug me at all i think cersei
and david charles is amazing um
i didn't look at all at her character
actually um
but i do understand the
the resemblance um
because i do remember her from watching
the show and i thought she was very very
strong
and what i loved about her character and
i think that that is something that i
really wanted for this character as well
is
the kind of the kind of strength that we
don't normally see and i don't want to
generalize but that we haven't really
seen in women as
uh as lead characters or as you know uh
more in-depth characters a lot uh we
have seen them of course but not a lot
that i think
what she represents in that role
is a certain kind of power
um or empowerment of of women female
empowerment that i loved seeing when i
was watching her character and i think
that for me was
oh hi that's it that's an amazing dog
this is iggy he might he
might make some noise along the way he's
on squirrel patrol he
i mean i'm in toronto filming and the
squirrels i love it they just don't stop
there's hundreds of them and he's the
best with them so yeah i hope you you'll
find one today anyway thank you
for joining i love the surprise guest
i know
um
but what was that yeah so i loved her
female empowerment and i loved the way
she took the character to different
level
and i think um that's one of the things
that i wanted to
do with um with queen kane
to to
show a certain kind of
uh
depths craziness sense of humor
all these things
um
that we often see in male characters
hey you shush
it's okay
and um
yeah so
yeah so that's where i started i think
for me it's very important when i take
on a role
uh that i get to explore that i get to
be free and because people aren't
logical
people aren't you know just
one-dimensional so sure i just wanted to
find all these characteristics to her
and i and it took me more to uh the male
side maybe or the male energy of the
character
um
which in the first c or one of the first
scenes that we see her masturbating
is was also very important to me to show
her
just
she's on her own she's praying to god
you know and and there's this dominant
energy inside of her that comes out um
and then just playing with that was just
fascinating to me and just gave me so
much it was very fun to do
yeah i mean and that that's like just
adding to like what was saying to you
like there's so many things you don't
know what to expect from her at any
given moment and
i think it's so interesting too you're
talking about taking kind of that male
energy into the character that's also
interesting i think a lot of actors and
actors like to hear that
kind of outside of the box thinking and
building a character now when you're
also building the character like this
saying like you said before that you're
playing a villain you like playing a
villain but
people some people on reddit will say
like oh this character is pure evil but
for you to play this type of character
do you
have to have some kind of sympathy for
her in your head like oh yeah i love her
yeah i love her which sounds
crazy of course
she kills people and she's horrible
but i love her i think she has
a certain kind of determination and she
has such a
you know um
just
an obsessed personality she starts
believing in her own lies uh
she invents what she wants to believe
and she believes in that she holds on to
that and i think
i mean
i'm not saying that i love that in a
human being but i i think it's
interesting it's
uh it could be
a very powerful characteristic if you if
you would use it for the good
you know
and
she just makes me laugh she cracks me up
and she takes me to different places
that haven't been before an actress
and i just hope
when the audience you know looks at her
that they
also see an opening
to
a person that's maybe
trying but
is also
in a way
um
[Music]
mentally maybe not capable or
mentally sick in a way she she doesn't
you know she she goes too far
um and and and have a certain kind yeah
i hope people see that and i hope people
have a certain kind of
as i do um
forgiveness for that or or love for that
or or heart for that you know
so but what you're saying there
yeah no and i get what you're saying
about like her going too far and she
kind of makes quick irrational decisions
sometimes i could say like destroying
her old city but like is there some sort
of suffering or maybe unresolved trauma
in her you kind of finding the character
that maybe causes this kind of behavior
yeah definitely um
so
you don't you don't see it much in the
show but uh
it is it is told that that is definitely
from the parents that her mother was
as crazy if not crazier than sibis
and um i think
she's very much like her mother and
mother was more like her father and
sibith
always
was fighting so hard for the
acknowledgement of her father and never
got it and
i think for me that was a personal fight
for
being normal like if if anything
as a person i could understand that she
wanted to be normal she wanted to be a
good queen
she wanted to be among living among
among the normal people healthy people
but she knew inside that there was
something about her that was not healthy
like it's a certain you know i took a
little bit from lady beth as well you
know it's like
she's trying to rub off
that that that
poison
you know the the the sickness inside of
her she can't you know and she wants to
be among the normal she wants to be
among the healthy of the nice
you know and the people that are
believed and are loved
but she goes too far because that
sickness within her just takes over
yeah and
it's interesting too you're talking
about that sickness within when it takes
over for you yourself how far do you let
yourself go into this character and what
i mean by that is when they call cut at
the end of a scene and you're filming do
you stay in that character are you able
to like tap in and out like how do you
find like a healthy balance
um
i would say tap in and out because we
have a lot of fun
we have a lot of fun on set
especially hera gilmore who plays
margaret and i uh we have a lot of fun
because the the the
the relationship between the sisters
that dynamic is just
you know
it's a childlike dynamic almost it's
like
you're playing with marbles and the one
has bigger and better marbles than the
other and you're just you're lying and
you're trying to figure a way to get her
marbles and
you know your fake
you fake it till you make it basically
and they both are doing that with each
other you know and it's just a fun
dynamic to
to work out and and and just that crazy
the the craziness that margaret brings
with his
is gigantic like she touches something
within sabbath that just grows and grows
and grows into more craziness and
sibbeth touches something in margaret
that grows into more strength than
actually
believing in the good and believing in
herself because
because of her craziness so
i guess
you know the
the dynamic between them is it's just a
lot of fun
and we get to be kids in a way a little
bit and um yeah no so i think i tap in
and out i do these weird things that
i realize when there's extras on set
they they tend to giggle and laugh when
i do it like
i do these weird things that are
actually it's very i'm a bit of shame
but i do these weird voice things that
um bring me into the character and when
i do them
when i see them i see all these extras
look at me like [ __ ] she's actually
[ __ ] crazy
actually
but it just takes me into the character
you know so in between days it's just
just sylvia you know but like
yeah just these little technical things
bring me into her
yeah her world
yeah that's actually amazing to hear and
i think people like hearing that that
you'll do those things on set and you
mentioned too you know the character of
margaret and how interesting the story
line is this season between the two of
you but i love the clippy shirt i think
it was today on instagram from i think
episode two where she calls you sibbeth
and you go who you know is that kind of
moment are you improvising at all with
her or is this all like straight from
the screen sometimes we definitely
improvise yeah there's a lot of freedom
but um but this was
it's just like that it's just that
uh yeah just the dynamic is it's just a
lot of fun um
and we definitely we definitely go and
change the rhythm and and kind of
explore the scene
um but uh you know i mean i just i just
remember i saw someone else posted and i
i just remembered
how much fun we had while we were doing
that scene and just the ridiculousness
of that who
you know um and and see how far we can
bring it and and see how far we could
make that more ridiculous you know
because i think with a character like
this it needs to have fun it needs to be
it needs to be you know you need to you
need to also enjoy her if you can't
enjoy that craziness then what what is
there there's just an evil queen there's
darkness but i want to enjoy this woman
like play with her have fun with her and
and laugh
about what she's doing like how [ __ ]
insane this woman is you know and also
myself i have a love for how insane she
is because she's she she's opening up
doors for me
to just be free and grow you know go
wild in a way you know
um
and i hope other people too because i
think
again i come back to that male female
thing again where i think for me
the assignment i feel like i have in my
career as a woman
is to
open up
these boundaries and the way people look
at women
that we don't oh that we don't only or
always have to be sexy or attractive or
good
but that we can be crazy and interesting
at the same time as well there's more to
us and i
i love those actresses that are able
to go there like my favorite actresses
are isabelle bear tilda swinton francis
dorman judy dench like those actresses
that
you know
dare to go there and i think
not only as an actress but to show women
little girls like you can be interesting
if you're [ __ ] crazy if you see
a fourth dimension you know if you see
beyond whatever we see there's there's
there's really some very powerful stuff
in that
yeah and i mean that's just an awesome
thing to leave off on there for people
listening and you know
you definitely go there and i would
definitely put you in that club with
those great actresses i mean we go from
blade runner to this like you're just a
scene stealer and i mean that in the
nicest way possible you're you're
amazing and i think people are really a
lot of people watching c are excited to
see your performance week to week so i'm
really honored to be talking to you
today everybody check out sylvia
memorize as queen kane in c season two
now a new episode every friday on apple
tv plus please check it out the show is
highly underrated so jump in while you
can
sylvia thank you so much for joining me
today and thank you thank you to your
dog as well
have a great
day
yes youtube thanks so much